- We're about to meditate
for two months straight.
- I signed up to do two
months of meditation.
- I don't really know much
about meditation in general.
- So we're going to meditate
for about two months every day
and see how it goes.
- Transcendental meditation is one thing.
It's a mental technique.
We always describe it as
simple, natural, and effortless.
Easy to do.
And what you're doing is,
a mental technique which
allows your mind and your body
to slow down.
- I'm not a real focused person.
When I was younger, it was even worse.
I couldn't even get
through a magazine article
without losing my concentration.
- I think I've gotten recently
way more attached to my phone.
The time that I used to spend
just with myself and my thoughts
I now am like, oh I have
some phone time now.
And so I think it'll just
cut out from my phone time,
which is great.
- I have big anxiety issue.
I'm basically hoping that meditation
would help me boost my self-confidence.
- I have a resting nice face
but a lot of times behind it,
it's just like panic.
So my expectation is to be calmer
and for my mind to race
less, if I could do this.
- I'm very excited.
- I really want it to work.
- I have to do it.
- We're here at the
David Lynch Foundation,
about to start our first day of training.
- I'm nervous, anxious.
- Last moment says just base,
terrible human beings.
- I just got my mantra and,
yeah, I feel really calm.
- I definitely feel tingly.
- It felt like such a release,
I actually started to cry a little bit.
- It felt like I was on the
bottom of a pool at a party,
watching the party go on above
and being super calm and chilled
out underneath the party.
- That was really interesting,
I didn't expect to go as
deep as I did right away.
- I was thinking very visual,
and there's one point where
I was, I felt like I
was flying in the wind.
- I think I'm going to try
drinking less caffeine,
because I feel like when I
have caffeine in my system
it makes me harder to
slow down my breathing.
- Then I saw a guy with a huge mouth.
- I'm hopeful, I have to say I'm hopeful,
and that feels really good.
- I just went into his
mouth and went inside.
And it was just pitch black.
- It's only been two days,
so very curious to see the changes
that could take place over two months.
- I've been pretty good.
I've been really good.
- Probably some of the
best weeks of my life.
- I'm a little bit more chipper.
- My mid-afternoon stress
headaches went away.
- I feel much less anxious and
I feel much more like myself,
like I'm not faking being
relaxed, I actually am relaxed.
- And I especially love
meditating with my cat.
(chimes)
- So last week I went camping
by myself in Joshua Tree.
I went off trails and I
started climbing boulders.
I got to the top of really high boulders,
but one time I could not go back down.
Just pretty fucking scary.
And I started to panic.
This drop...
I just couldn't find a place
to put my hands or my feet
and I couldn't go down.
And if I just jumped down, I'm gonna die.
My heart's beating really
fast, I could feel it,
and I was really scared.
And I told myself, relax, go meditate.
So literally I'm meditating
on top of the boulder.
Couple minutes later I open
my eyes and I felt so calm.
And easily, I got back down.
It really relieved my stress and my worry.
It definitely helped save my life.
- I feel really good about
transcendental meditation.
- Meditation had a very
positive impact on my life
- I'm sad when I don't meditate.
- It makes me aware of my own company,
that I can be alone and have
a fulfilling time with myself.
- When I meditate, I'm
much more in the now.
- It kinda puts more distance between
me finding something
out and me freaking out.
There's another option besides
freak out and be stressed.
- You know, I was shy, not very confident.
- My anxiety is diminished,
and my ability to focus on
the task at hand is increased.
- I think I used to fill
time with trash content,
like Instagram, or Twitter,
or just constantly stimulating
myself with filler.
- I think that I will continue
doing this indefinitely,
at least I hope I do.
- I wanna keep doing it.
- It's just become so normal
to me, so part of my routine.
- I'm spreading the gospel
of meditation to everybody.
- It's just there and I love it.